Hello again, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters for another episode of Cutters Clinic Online.
Today I have a very special guest hike. Bloomberg comes to us from
orthomolecular products. It's a product line that we carry. They're all based out of Wisconsin,
which is nice for us to get product quickly. Boy, we appreciate that. And they just have a great
reputation of science based in their product line that a lot of research goes beyond, you know,
just the regular supplements. So we really appreciate that as well.
Tag, tell us a little bit about you, how you got into nutritional supplements and
promotion. Yeah, so quickly, I won't spend too much time on my history, but at the time,
I was working at Boston Scientific. And they're a, for those that don't know, they're a med
device company in Arden Hills, Minnesota, formerly guidance. And I did pacemakers,
deputulators, heartbeat devices. So I was kind of an expert in that area of medicine.
In the meantime, personally, my younger brother, who was 25 at the time, ended up getting cancer.
He called me and basically told me he had a backache, and I told him to go see his chiropractor,
which is, you know, sound advice typically, but he said it's a different kind of pain.
I don't know what's going on. So he went and got checked out by his regular doc, and they ended
up finding a tumor on a spine. And he got the whole Mayo workout done, which included like an RPL
and D surgery. So they basically cut him open, removed all of his organs and 23 lymph nodes,
and did a big major surgery with, it was hot. So that got me looking into functional medicine.
That's how my journey started was there must be a better way or a preventative way to so that
no one has to go through such a dramatic thing. So that was, that's what got me interested in
functional medicine. So I reached out to ortho molecular products. So I get to work with around 600
clinics in the state. And it's been a phenomenal journey for the last seven years. I wouldn't go
back for anything. So great. With ortho molecular products, you have a numerous ones that we like.
And what you're dealing with functional medicine, one of the first things that we know that we have
to work on is trying to heal the gut. So you have a very unique product that we use a lot in our
office. And let's let's talk about that today. The clear SBI protect. Tell us everything you know
about SBI protected. Why a person would use that? Yeah. So this is a product that was new to us
in 2018. And we're lucky enough for a large enough nutrition company where we get certain exclusive
products that are only offered through our company, which is nice for a few different reasons. But
this one in particular, it's good because we believe that the GI system is kind of the center of
a lot of the other systems in the body. And taking care of that first, as you mentioned, is kind of
paramount to the path of healing. So this product is crucial. The SBI portion stands for serum
derived bovine immunoglobulins. And that's a fancy word for where we usually get immunoglobulins
from. It's from colostrum, right? So this is a serum derived version, which would make it dairy-free.
And the reason that's important is when you're trying to heal someone's gut who might have
leaky gut syndrome or hyper permeability, they call it. You don't want to introduce potential
palrogens like dairy into their system because that will cause inflammation. So we have the only
dairy-free IGG product on the market. And you mentioned you use a lot of it. That's a very good thing
because its mechanism of actions very simple and it's safe for anyone to take.
You can give it to an infant or a child, an adult, someone who's chronically ill,
and there are no side effects that are known. So there's no taste to it, so you can mix the powder
into anything from applesauce, almond milk, water, it doesn't matter. So
and we can talk a little bit about the mechanism too.
Firstly, the people will probably ask, what's it a beautiful globular? Why do I need a beautiful
globular? So talk about how it binds microbes and pathogens in the gut to give a little history there.
Yeah, it has a really cool mechanism of action. And the reason I think it's cool is because it's
so simple. And so basically you have your gut lining. And I don't know if you want me to share my
screen or not, but I could put a little diagram up here. So this graphic is kind of, it represents
what's going on in our gut lining. On the the red side of things where it says suboptimal,
that's kind of your standard chronically ill patient. And you can see the the circle where it says
one there under altered gut microbiota. So that that just means you have an unbalanced or a
dysbiotic state in your gut where there's more harmful things than there are good things. So that
balance is shifted in the wrong direction. And then you have increased antigen penetration which
means that those bad things are going down through the gut lining and they're stimulating a response
that's the third step there is increased immune activation. So basically what's going on is you
have these specialized immune cells called macrophages. And those are gobbling up those bad things at a
rate that they can handle, typically. And then they turn into what's called an APC or an antigen
presenting cell, which allows the immune system then to safely test fragments of whatever that bad
thing was to see whether the immune system needs to respond or not. So in the case of hyper permeability
or severely ket syndrome or whatever you want to call it, there's too many pathogens making
their way through and the immune system literally keep up. So it's sounding the alarm saying,
hey, we have more, you know, more work on our plate than we can handle. So let's just call everything
bad until we know what's going on. And that's where you can get in some dangerous autoimmunity and
different allergies developed and whatnot. So you might be wondering, you know, that's great,
but what is SBI doing to help that? And if you look on the optimal side of the diagram right here,
it says the first one is microbial balance. So the first step that SBI does a really good job in
doing is binding to pathogenic organisms for those bad guys in your gut microbiome. So it binds to them.
It actually makes that structure larger than it initially was. And it makes it much harder for it to
travel through these channels in between your endocrine cells and stimulate that immune response.
So think about it like like clustering up on those bad guys and then they're forced out through
this stool. They can't elicit an immune response in the room. The other thing that SBI does is
they use receptor sites for what's called zonulin. And for those that don't know what zonulin is,
it's basically a chemical that unlocks the door for these channels to develop inside the gut.
So the more of that, you can stop the better. And things that cause zonulin release would be like
pathogenic organisms. So think like gram-negative bacteria, things like E. coli, cell manila,
you know, all the bad bits throughout there. Also gluten is a big, gluten basically sits on
that gut lining and turns into a substance called gliadin. And then gliadin creates zonulin
which unlocks the door for more hyper permeability or more leaky gut syndrome. So those are the two main
things that's doing in the gut from a mechanism of action standpoint. And again, this is totally
safe for everybody to take and very, very effective because as you can imagine, those with autoimmunity
or any sort of immune challenge, this is just taking the burden off of the immune system so that it can
play catch up in essence. So the third thing that I haven't mentioned is because it's blocking zonulin
in the gut level, it also does that for the blood brain barrier. And why that's important is obviously
you have a gut barrier. You also have a barrier to your brain that's less permeable but still can
allow some things through that shouldn't be there. And when that happens, you get things like brain
fog memory issues early onset Alzheimer's, you know, it starts off small but does progress over time.
So if you can keep neuro inflammation at bay by keeping that barrier good, that's also a very good
situation. So I'd say those those three things are really what the crux of SBI is doing
from a mechanism standpoint. Yeah, it would be hard to argue that this product would not be good for
everybody. So it's it's one of those products that we tend to recommend as a beneficial thing for
everybody. It makes no difference whether you got cancer or my more or thyroid issues or headaches.
When you talk about inflammation or the gut, it can equate to inflammation everywhere in your body.
So decreasing that initial source of inflammation is key in our book.
An SBI protect is a great product. Now you said you're the only company that carries this product.
Is that correct? That is correct. Yes, we have the the parent company has signed an exclusive
agreement with us. So it's available as a pharmaceutical and then also as a nutraceutical only
through our company. Right. Yeah, we're really excited about it. Well, thanks so much.
I'd like to have you back again on another episode. I want to talk about like the next step.
If we're going to use amythoglobulins to bind microbes and pathogens, but also to bind, you know,
inner substances with SBI production help clear that out of the body and clear that out to the gut.
But next step is to how do we reanoculate the gut? What probiotics are good probiotics to use to help
reanoculate the gut to deal with that systemic inflammation? So I'd love to have you back again.
Would that be okay? Yeah, I would love to talk about that. Talk about how to heal those tissues and how
to get that gut microbiota back on the right track again. All right. Thank you so much.
Thank you. Wonderful. Thank you for having me on. Yep. I appreciate it.